[Music]
what's up wisecrack
jared here through researching these
deeper dumb videos we've managed to find
complexity in the corners of pop culture
where you'd least
expect it in the work of nicholas cage
for instance or in films like shrek
which
seems shallow at first glance but turns
out to be surprisingly deep
onions have layers ogres
have layers onions have layers you get
it we both have layers we like to think
we've gotten
reasonably good at extracting meaning
from silly cultural artifacts
still when intrepid wisecrack writer
miles approached us wanting to cover
smash mouth my eyes rolled so thoroughly
i think i lost them in the back of my
head
who in the world would consider smash
mouth's ubra to be even remotely deep
much less secretly super brilliant if i
were to suggest such a thing
you would eat me alive in the comments
and well you'd be right to do so
if you've heard even a handful of their
songs you likely think that smashmouth's
music is pretty superficial
but miles pictured here after immersing
himself in their entire discography for
three straight weeks
thinks he's discovered something more in
smash mouth's work than frat rockers
whining about ex-girlfriends and
swooning over current ones
now we had our doubts but when miles
locked the doors to the wisecrack
offices from the outside and refused to
let us leave without hearing his pitch
we literally could not say no here's
miles angle
against all odds the band best known for
providing the background music to
shrek's morning
shower and shave the three s's
has also created songs that engage with
ideas from wisecrack fan favorite
philosophers like jean-paul sartre
and albert camus don't believe him well
i don't blame you but we're gonna dive
in
anyway and maybe i'll prove to you that
this isn't just a case of my brain
getting smart while my head gets dumb
so welcome to this wisecrack edition on
smash mouth deep
or dumb allow me to take you back to the
year 1997.
it was a different time a simpler time
titanic sparked a nationwide interest in
larger door frames
george clooney answered questions about
bat nipples we didn't even know we had
and the recently released star wars
special editions gave us a sneak peek at
what it would feel like to have our
childhoods ruined
there was a steve jobs in every apple a
tamagotchi on every belt
and americans knew exactly what it was
that the spice girls are really really
really wanted
enter smash mouth not quite young and
blonde enough to be in sync and not
quite talented enough to be back
the band occupied a murky place in pop
culture
they wrote catchy pop songs that gave
you ear worms for days
and that's about it but according to
miles from the band's early days through
the departure of the main songwriter and
guitarist greg camp in 2008
smash mouth repeatedly explored some of
the key themes of
existentialism in its lyrics but what is
existentialism existentialism can
sometimes be tricky to define with a
diverse set of thinkers taking up the
label but we'll say
broadly it's a philosophy concerned with
the basic questions of human existence
there are two questions that perpetually
rise up for many existentialists that
are relevant to our discussion here
authenticity and the search for meaning
unlike philosophers from centuries past
thinkers like sartre couldn't just turn
to god for answers to these questions
because to him god doesn't exist and so
we're on our own to find the answers an
existentialist like camus sees the
universe as
essentially indifferent to humanity it
has no inherent meaning
and is mostly the place where we just
hang out while we're waiting to die
but for someone like sartre this
quandary offers the opportunity to make
our own meaning here's where smash mouth
comes in
our world according to their vast
catalogue of mediocrity
is a wacky out of control place with
little regard for the people in it
this is most apparent in what is
probably the band's most famous song
all-star if i may read a passage the ice
sweep skate is getting pretty thin
the water's getting warm so you might as
well swim my world's on fire
how about yours that's the way i like it
and i never get bored we're not the
first to suggest that these lyrics seem
to be talking about climate change
a fact actually confirmed by the
songwriter so
sure the song evokes global warming but
this is also the first piece of evidence
in miles claim
on the surface it's simply if life gives
you global climate change
make unseasonably warm pool parties but
this will be our first hint that smash
mouth is speaking more broadly to the
human condition
and here we should look to
existentialist albert camus who proposed
the philosophy of absurdism
or the idea that the universe is a cruel
joke that is indifferent to our
existence
we are conscious beings in an
unconscious universe
out of our control and our job involves
skating on thin ice in a world that is
sometimes literally on fire so far this
comparison seems like a stretch but when
considered with the band's other lyrics
the message starts to come into focus
allegedly
take the song hang on which compares the
human condition to that of being
constantly at the mercy of a wild
rampaging animal let's look to the text
you'll never make everybody's day but
while you're around you might as well
catch the tiger by its tail
and hang on hang on hang on compare that
to
this monologue from another famous
existentialist rick sanchez
when you know nothing matters the
universe is yours and i've never met a
universe that was into it
the universe is basically an animal it
grazes on the ordinary
creates infinite idiots just to eat them
not unlike your friend timmy
tommy yeah hardly matters now sweetie
you know smart people get a chance to
climb on top
take reality for a ride but it'll never
stop trying to throw you
and eventually it will there's no other
way off now i'm not going to say that
greg camp and steve harwell are our very
own universe's rick sanchez and morty
smith but
i'm not not going to say that
importantly though absurdism is not the
same as hedonism
and there's ample evidence to suggest
that this song is more hedonistic than
absurdist
a hedonist posits immediate pleasure as
in sex
chocolate and puppies but not all at
once as the ultimate purpose of life
and we can say that the lyrics
essentially amount to things will never
be great so
might as well get wild itself a form of
meaning camus would likely reject
alternative reading to exist in our
universe is akin to being eternally
stuck in 2003's live cat and a hat
remake
for which this song was a tie-in i'll
get you and i look like a bloody
accident
incidentally ask miles to explain the
weird connections between smash mouth
mike myers and the children's film
industry in the early 2000s
anyway back to camu a little bit
confusingly kamu's rejection of meaning
did not translate to saying
it and becoming a couch potato the dude
later wrote a book called the rebel
that encouraged others to rise up and
revolt in the name of something larger
than themselves
we're not even going to try to suggest
that smash mouth invokes camus work in
the rebel
but from their masterpiece so insane
have you checked out the temperature
lately there's a fever that's about to
break
we got the hands to turn this around we
got the plan to make it go down
we got the voice fill in this room we
got the minds the minds that go boom
get up get out get on that train it's
becoming so insane
this tiny blue marble is rolling away
not convinced
let's try again in the context of this
wild universe smash mouth perhaps
also plays with the existentialist idea
of bad faith
as outlined by jean-paul sartre rather
than lulling at the universe's
indifference like camus
sartre claims that the good
existentialist life is one lived
authentically according to principles we
choose out of a pure act of free will
rather than what is convenient or
fashionable at any given time
the opposite of this is living in bad
faith or consciously mitigating your
responsibility to choose
in the song shoes and hats smash mouth
offers a critique of bad faith that it
gives sartre the warm and fuzzies
in my old chapeau well it's full of
holes but it's got more soul than them
they who are they anyway they're just
beating each other
at being each other with nothing to say
our narrator who defies convention by
wearing shabby clothes has
more soul than people who spend lots of
time and effort
beating each other at being each other
rather than being unique
authentic individuals with particular
likes and wants
the aforementioned hang on also upholds
individual authenticity as more
important than conformity or
people-pleasing since you'll never make
everybody's day
it doesn't make sense from an
existentialist standpoint to try
and of course we can never forget who it
is that breaks the mo
world
this one seems like a stretch as
tempting as it is to say that smash
mouth is condemning people who don't
embrace their freedom by trying to be
like others
it's likely just a generic call for
authenticity that exists as much with
goths who complain about posers as it
does with french philosophers who chain
smoked all day
okay now before we get too deep into the
song that probably brought like
75 percent of you here let's get back to
camu you might have heard of a guy named
sisyphus
a king condemned to spend eternity
rolling a boulder up a hill
only to have it roll down again he's a
central figure for camus who argues in
the myth of sisyphus that we find
ourselves in a situation very much like
that faced by this mythological
character
if existentialists like sartre wanted to
assert some higher calling in the world
like authenticity
kamu wanted to point out the utter
pointlessness of that effort
and suggest what he thought was a better
way of dealing with our lot
namely facing up to it directly and
learning to appreciate it in spite of
the suckiness
according to camus one of the defining
features of human existence is the
conflict between our need for meaning
and the universe's indifference to our
goals and suffering
like sisyphus we put enormous amounts of
effort into achieving particular goals
and like him we inevitably end up back
where we started
without a sense of permanent
accomplishment this is the essence of
camus absurd
he argues that the best possible
response is to do what sisyphus does
embrace the absurdity of our existence
and be happy
smash mouth allegedly encourages
listeners to approach the absurdity of
existence in the same manner
while so insane asks us to fix the world
allstar
asks us to learn to love our crumbling
hellscape
to quote they're magnum opus well the
years start coming and they don't stop
coming
fed to the rules and i hit the ground
running didn't make sense not to live
for fun
your brain gets smart but your head gets
dumb so much to do
so much to see so what's wrong with
taking the back streets
now this might be simply hedonism given
that the years don't stop coming and
making life a headlong dive toward the
grave
it literally makes no sense to do
anything other than live for fun
that is to spend one's life finding and
pursuing the things that bring the
greatest amount of subjective
fulfillment
but maybe just maybe it's a reminder
that death will come for us all
and that like sisyphus we should find
happiness in the absurdity of our world
in a sort of similar way holiday in my
head conveys the
idea that meaning is arbitrary rather
than objective
and that this is a cause for celebration
without externally imposed meanings to
trap us in particular ways of being
we are free to run our lives as we wish
you look around at your sleepy little
town and think that this is as good as
it gets
well what you're looking at is heaven
sent i got a holiday in my head
i'm just looking for paradise in my
living room according to miles's
existentialist reading
smash mouth argues that it doesn't
matter what sleepy little town you find
yourself stuck in
whether that be a dead-end job or your
own barricaded office space
or any other situation that at first
glance appears boring and meaningless
we may create a holiday in our head at
any time we choose
regardless of our external conditions
it's a cheerier version of camus
protagonist murseau
in the stranger after being sent to
prison and sentenced to death for murder
he creates his own holiday in his head
as he opens his heart to the
indifference of the universe and
cheerily imagines the spectators
furiously denouncing him at his own
execution
or less bleakly if sisyphus can find
enjoyment in pushing a rock up a hill
forever
we can certainly look around for the
paradise in our living room
no matter how your futon is but if
you're looking to find absurdism
distilled in song form
it'd be hard to beat story of my life in
which the narrator describes his endless
run of bad luck
and his affirmative response to it it
doesn't matter what i do
i just can't seem to win but here i go
again
now if this is just some self-help esque
when you get knocked down get up again
mumbo jumbo it's not kamu
but if this is some acceptance of the
incessant often pointless effort of life
then it's pretty absurdist like sisyphus
rolling that boulder uphill
watching it roll down and rolling it
back up again the narrator keeps
engaging with life
no matter how many times it kicks him in
the balls even when his attempts to
socialize and find love are thwarted by
his own
rotten luck and ineptitude he decides
he'll go again
to quote camus the struggle itself
toward the heights is enough to fill a
man's heart
one must imagine steve harwell happy
now did the members of smash mouth read
a truckload of sartre and camus back in
the early 90s and decide to create a
band
dedicated to spreading existentialist
ideas
probably not but the band's emphasis on
authenticity
positivity and chinstrap beards in the
face of bad or indifferent circumstances
definitely strikes a chord with those of
us who have a soft spot for a certain
brand of depressing european philosophy
nevertheless it's really hard to say any
of this is deep with a straight face
so sorry miles we're gonna have to say
dumb
please let us out of the office but what
do you think wisecrack was this hostage
situation
all for naught is miles reading meaning
into these songs that isn't
quite there or have we barely begun to
scratch the surface of what smash mouth
can tell us
about this crazy adventure called life
let us know in the comments
god help us and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you